we should have violent Sports if  anything we should have more of them  because a violent sport like football is  among other things a relatively safe  relatively productive outlet for male  energy and aggression okay there's a  reason why many of the media articles  being written and freaking out about  football are being written by women the  Crux of his argument is women shouldn't  have a say because men are the ones that  have violent urges and you chicks don't  get it I would actually almost accept  that argument from this Tool Shed if I  knew that he had no opinions on abortion  female reproductive rights price of  tampons but I know this  bearded  douche nozzle has so much to say about  women that he knows nothing about so for  him to turn around be like women I don't  even want to hear from you because you  guys just don't shut up lady listen if  you want to be included in the football  conversation you're not helping your  case here